[Musique]
on ratisse en vieillissant vrai ou faux
c'est vrai on passe une bonne partie de
notre vie à grandir mais aussi une bonne
partie de notre vie a rapetissé
et il n'y a pas d'égalité des sexes ici
leur et précis cement est plus marquée
chez les femmes que chez les hommes à
l'âge de 70 ans
en moyenne les femmes auront perdu 5 cm
et s'ils se rendent jusqu'à 80 ans c'est
7,5 cm de moins mais les hommes ne sont
pas épargnés à l'âge de 72 ans ils
auront rapetisser de 2 5 cm en moyenne à
81 5 cm savary de toute façon énormément
d'une personne à l'autre mais on peut
dire que grosso modo à partir de 40 ou
50 ans on peut s'attendre à perdre un
centime est retardé c'est la grande
responsable c'est la colonne vertébrale
entre chacune de nos 24 vertèbres on a
des genres de petits coussins des
disques qui assure la flexibilité de la
colonne et qui lui permettent de
supporter du bois mais avec le temps
l'usure fait son oeuvre et nos petits
poussins perdre une partie du fluide qui
se trouvent dans leur partie centrale il
s'aplatissent et la colonne ce compris
dans les faits chaque jour on ratisse
d'un sentiment oui oui chaque jour parce
que la gravité tire notre colonne
vertébrale vers le bas écrasement
coussin qui perdent une partie de leur
véhicule
à 1 cm par jour on devrait avoir disparu
depuis longtemps mais non parce que
chaque soir on s'allonge à l'horizontale
les disques ray absorbe du fluide et on
regrette dit
mais chaque soir on se couche bel et
bien plus petit qu'on l'était le matin
les astronautes subissent exactement l
inverse
pendant leur séjour prolongé à bord de
la station spatiale internationale en
apesanteur la gravité une cire plus
leurs colonnes vers le bas la colonne
peut s'étirer et y gagnent plusieurs
centimètres
par exemple pendant une mission de six
mois un astronaute d'un mètre
quatre-vingt peut gagner 5 cm mais
aussitôt qu'elle revient sur terre la
gravité recommence à faire son oeuvre et
il va retrouver sa taille originale
si on vient les deux pieds sur terre à
part l'aplatissement des 10 de la
colonne vertébrale l'arthrose peut aussi
nous faire quelques cyr en s'attaquant
au cartilage de l'articulation
l'ostéoporose aussi en allant faire
rapetisser les zoos humains et la perte
de masse musculaire qui entraîne des
problèmes de posture
évidemment tous ces faits là avec de
bonnes habitudes de vie
à défaut de les éviter on peut au moins
les limiter